and you you might not be a real judge
but based on your robe and your
pigmentation I would swear that you were
I got all the tools right yes you got
all two robed in white
you look like ready to go you look like
a God he gave me seven years before no
you do how I apologize for that
on behalf of all of us when you get
seven years for I was a stick-up kid I
was a stick-up kids just a young
misguided individual who really needed a
chance coming up in the inner city
lacking a father figure I've seen that
movie a bunch of times
why isn't that movie fix the problem
they keep making it efficient keeps
occurring I don't know I don't know you
know what I was thinking in there I was
thinking they should bring back corded
phones because then these things well
these incidents will stop happening with
the people getting phones thrown at them
because if the phones got a cord on it
you know just it'll just snap back right
away you know what and that actually can
work a few ways because like any event
that you throw your phone and hit
somebody in the head and you know you
can't retrieve your phone it's nice to
be able to get it back again
get your phone yeah kind of like a
bungee fall but you got to become like a
ninja there's got to be a master a
because if you throw it wrong and come
back and pop you right in the mouth or
something so you know sometimes karma
that would be embarrassing but karma may
need to intervene sometimes hey just
tell the receptionist ladies don't grind
a wheat up they're small no more and
they know I'm coming that got to ground
up they got to ground up cuz you know I
smoked in the bus you gotta have some
chunky buzz in here but I understand oh
you like to have some chunky bugs and I
do all right
chunky style Charlie you got a really
sharp you gots a show you got you like
sharks in your
Reese's and things like that and your
Snickers - Snickers always says strong
soon I don't want a shocks of my Reese's
those will be smooth creamy peanut
butter okay where do you like your songs
then just you know just in a blunt I
like I like my chunky bullish shonky
buzz and chunky bank accounts
okay
[Music]